did you ever think you would make it I
feel I'm tastet Victory I know this life
for
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David value giv values
contagious this world on preneurs we get
no value to haters run homie look what I
become I'm I'm the one
okay today we have a special podcast I
always respect anybody that is willing
to go on any podcast and talk game I got
a lot of respect for people like that
before we were going live I was telling
I said I said Steve why does everybody
love you and he was getting ready to
answer I said let's just wait till the
podcast start for him to explain to us
why everybody loves him but let me
explain to uh who he is in 2007 he was
recognized as the campaign manager of
the year uh he's done a lot of different
work he's been the political and
corporate strategist with experience in
campaigns with President Bush Arnold
Schwarzenegger and John McCain he's
worked as a vice chair at edman advised
Fortune 500 corporations later on became
MSNBC political analyst he gained
attention for his critical stance on
Donald Trump and the Republican Party
eventually renouncing the GOP I think as
of December of 2020 you became a
Democrat or 20201 one of those two dat
to became a Democrat and in 2019 he
co-founded the Lincoln project a super
pack aimed at opposing Trump's 2020
reelection however he left the group in
February of 2021 he is currently the
founder of warning newsletter a YouTube
channel and podcast it's actually good
YouTube channel we're going to put the
link below for people to be able to go
see he gives us feedback you may or may
not agree what he has to say but he
gives his point of view and then last
but not least I always think about if
somebody was to play a role of me in a
movie who I would want to play the guy
right it's a very imp like I would like
John Bernthal I'm a big fan of John
Bernthal but imagine in a 2012 HBO movie
called Game Change Woody harelson plays
you okay that's exactly what happened
and our guest today Steve Schmid Steve
thank you for being on the podcast it's
great to be with you guys thanks for
having me yes so why do people love you
what is this with you man I guess it's
the good hair
right killing the game yeah um yeah look
you know you get into you get into
politics you assert a you you assert a
conviction um you know for person who
cheers you there's there's one out there
that wants to hang you and that's the
that's the reality in the country today
is we have a we have a real lack of
Tolerance right you know for somebody
hearing something they disagree with
yeah and and really at an emotional
level at an adult level at a pragmatic
level they just can't handle it I I know
a lot of people a lot of people would
say with you guys when when what you did
with Lincoln project uh for for people
who don't know maybe if you do or you
don't know Lincoln project many would
say you guys played a big role in
President Trump not getting reelected
okay I think a lot of people would say
that right I think that's right I think
that's what the reputation would be
because you were able to get a lot of
people from the Republican side to not
want to vote for Trump and you were
trashing them bashing them Non-Stop and
there's obviously a lot of controver
that came afterwards with Lincoln
project we'll talk about that but at
first you know I I want to talk about
your background because there's only
about 10 of you in in the world in
America today that can talk about what
it is to win a campaign lose a campaign
mistakes you make things you do right
things you do wrong I remember one time
I'm in La at Wayne Hugh's house in uh
Malibu and I'll never forget he brought
the campaign manager at the time of uh
GES am I saying uh what's his what's his
name something Gillespie U anyways it
was two people one was for Clinton's
campaign manager and he brought Bush's
campaign manager maybe he was one of the
two and they debated for an hour and a
half friendly debate but they debated
for an hour and a half one of them
eventually later on ended up running for
governor in Virginia dad glasby that's
what it is yeah and then the other one
very gentle mannered guy he was Bush's
guy and just sitting there you're
watching this you're thinking they're
going to talk policies the entire time
but it was all strategy on how to get
the other person to win or lose so for
you let's go to your background like who
you were before how you came into this
business and then we'll go into Lincoln
project so before you got into politics
maybe walk us through who you were in
high school in 10th Grade 11th grade
weren classmates together who was Steve
uh I was uh you know I was a striver I
think of trying to please right so I was
I was on the football team but I was
also playing in the marching band for
competitions I was vice president of the
class I was an eagle scout I was you
know president of the National Honor
Society all that stuff and then um I
went to college and uh I wound up being
the uh scholar of my pledge class in the
fraternity and I got a 1.9 GPA that
semester so I one
point I I I rebelled in my college Years
but I but I grew up in a I grew up in a
middle class town north planfield New
Jersey there's a uh there's a
documentary out right now called
telemarketers about the this this the
largest telemarketing scam in American
history all these guys were from the
town I grew up in they were two classes
ahead of me it was a uh
was overwhelmingly Italian American uh
town but very ethnic um I remember my
mother when I was N9 or 10 years old uh
you know I asked her why doesn't dad go
to church with us and uh you she took a
deep sigh and she goes you know uh you
your dad's a Protestant and it was like
what's what's a Protestant right there
were Jews there were Catholics and
across the Little Creek was an all black
City and there those were the Baptist
churches right so that it was a it was a
it was an
ethnic Melting Pot working class
Suburban bedroom New Jersey Community
kind of coming an age of Ronald Reagan's
America I distinctly
remember um in 1979 really the first
issue that had consciousness of that you
were drawn to watching the news what's
going on was the Iranian hostage crisis
and um so followed that race always
loved politics and um you know was drawn
to it from a from a little kid you know
working on campaigns as a volunteer all
that stuff now were Mom and Dad talking
politics in the house were they involved
or they they had no interest so this is
purely you yeah purely me got it
interesting okay so then later on what's
your you know how do you end up working
with you know President Bush Arnold and
McCain how does that happen that happens
after a decade on the road as an iin
campaign worker right you know going
from campaign to campaign had a
Mitsubishi Eclipse I own as I owned uh I
owned one own was it was a turbo uh St
manual manual it had uh I owned one big
pot one big spoon I had a stereo right
they got stolen out of that Mitsubishi
Eclipse so that was gone but like I had
my clothes and you would go to whatever
campaign and really had an opportunity
to live all over the country so I lived
in you know Pikeville Kentucky silaga
Alabama uh Southbend Indiana and it
really gave me gave me an impression of
the of the country is kind of my career
moves into National politics I wind up
working in the white house and doing all
this
stuff that when I look at politics like
right now I mean I've
never been cognizant of a moment where
there's more complete Detachment in
Washington from what's going on in real
people's lives out in the out in the
country I just drove across the country
um 4200 mile road trip and my
overwhelming impression was how little
of what I ever see on the news has
anything to do with these people's lives
out there so I wasn't somebody who went
to Harvard in Yale got an internship for
the Federal judge wound up in Washington
and kind of wound up in the in the White
House I came from a track of on the
political campaigns and you know at the
end of the day you might have a thousand
people working on a political campaign
but there's about 10 you know maybe less
that are that are really calling the
shots making the decision about how to
play an extremely complicated game uh
that's that's one of the greatest just
stepping back from all the
politic it is it is a it is the greatest
non-lethal competition in the world is
the race for the presidency of the of
the United States it's a it's an
intense
nonstop experience and um you know my
experience of of having lived out there
in the country I think definitely
prepared me better for it for those
three campaigns Camp so so let me ask so
you ever the movie Moneyball with Billy
Bean Brad Pit Okay so we've had Paul
maniff for here we've had Roger Stone
here we've had a lot of different kinds
of people here to get perspect we've had
Jen Jen yuger from Young Turks we've had
a lot of people Cuomo and I ask the
people that are in the
space in baseball they finally figured
out that the most important stat for a
hitter is what onb based percentage
that's what matters if you want to you
know sell the audience you got to hit
home runs but if you want to win and go
into playoffs it's on based percentage
right Roger Stone talks about certain it
fact actor that a person's got to have
right just a couple nights ago we're
having dinner and I'm talking about why
some content creators do very well and
we wrote out a bunch of different names
and we gave all of them grades okay and
the highest grade I think was Rogan had
the highest grade out of everybody and
these are four things we wrote it on
number one is content he can pretty much
talk on almost many different levels of
content right so what is the content
you're providing number two is
entertainment you're entertaining to
listen to number three is personality
it's an attractive personality that you
have it's not an annoying obnoxious
personality you don't like and number
four is storytelling you're good at
telling stories right now that's for
Content creating in
politics um and then in sports you know
I'll talk to Shaq or Kobe and I'll say
what what matters the most Superstar GM
or team owner to to win a championship
is it or head coach right if you own a
is it is it the owner that makes the
team win a championship because he's
committed to a championship so he spends
the money is it the head coach is it the
GM or is it the Superstar you got to get
like a you know Giannis or LeBron or
Kobe or MJ right what is that for
winning elections whether it's Governor
or president for you that's been in the
space your entire life okay and you're a
killer you're hated by those who can't
stand you because you're you can get as
dirty as anybody else there was a part
that you know I think in the interview
60 Minutes that was doing an interview
with you guys and they ask it sounds
like you're willing to get as dirty as
possible to make sure this man doesn't
win they're like yeah absolutely it
wasn't like you guys were hesitating
you're not trying to be well no not re
that's not your play your play you're
just like no this is who we are we want
to make sure this guy never wins and
doesn't step another foot in the white
house right okay from your experience to
get somebody to win what things do you
need from The Supporting Cast and then
from the other side what qualities does
the talent the candidate need to stand a
chance at winning so at the beginning of
the Bush
campaign the it's clear that John carry
is going to be the nominee and so the
Bush campaign turns on and I had I was
in charge of anything that had to do
with John krey it was kind of the tip of
the spear in the in the campaign and so
as the campaign turns on if we were a
football team our first 10 plays were
three
turnovers personal foul two offsides and
a delay of game and we get a call about
10 12 of us and it says
be at the White House after after uh
after work uh you're going to meet the
president up in the residence he wants
to talk to
everybody and we were like oh like
we're get we're getting fired like a
week into this um and so we go up there
and and Carl Rove is sitting there
president walks in he was in a really
good mood and um you bush is a bush is
an intense guy um I think you see him on
TV now like like you know I look at him
like my dad right he's mellowed out a
little bit spends all the time painting
yeah but he he was an intense guy and
and he came in and question he asked he
goes who's the most experienced
political consultant in the room and
everyone looks at Ro and he goes it's me
right he goes he goes he goes my dad's
8084 8892 campaign he goes through this
whole thing and he says American
presidential campaign has an accidental
genius to it
in that it never ends right in Canada
they have an election they call it right
it's going to be in 90 days or in
Britain 120 days this goes on for years
and what he says
is this is a character test he goes all
my flaws you guys will try to cover them
up mitigate them he goes it never work
never
work you go go he goes you are seen for
who you are now David Axelrod he
expressed this by saying it's like an
MRI for the soul that's what a
presidential campaign is and so Bush at
the end of this meeting goes he goes
we're going to win he goes because John
car's an
says this bush says this at the
at the meeting right but I've always had
that frame right it's a character test
so so in the campaign what do you need
you need harmony right as an
organization you need Vision to
communicate to the country uh
typically uh and what will happen again
is a frame and a lens of what we share
in common what unites the American
people a vision for moving the country
forward uh with a recognition that at
the end of the election right we're all
living here together and all of our kids
are going to be living here together I
think some of the people you talked
about you know I served in the white
house um and I've run big
campaigns Lincoln project hit as hard as
it could
hit there was not one ad that was an
untruthful ad not one that was ever
called out every ad was an assertion of
opinion and it was an assertion of
belief some people may not like that but
one of the things we have in the in the
country that's gone off the rails is an
expectation that every everyone who does
this is a Serial liar who's going to lie
to you 35,000
times and that is a huge problem in this
country right now but go go back to it
so this is very interesting to say and I
we're going to come back to the
credibility of Lincoln project in a few
minutes but I want to stay on this so
what what an interesting thing I've had
Bush President Bush at an event before
the same event we had Kobe we had
President Bush there as well I had a
45-minute conversation the back with him
and they hit the stage it was very
interesting watching how he is and a lot
of people that couldn't stand him
afterwards they were you know hey you
know like his approach cuz he talked
about his flaws mistakes he made alcohol
was very interesting on how he is today
you're saying he was intense back then
but go back I want to know what matters
more is it the best campaign manager I
have a shitty candidate with the best
campaign manager is that person going to
win or is it you need a candidate that
has this this this this and this for
example the reason why uh many people
liked uh what president Trump did he was
the best anti-establishment guy that
we've seen in a long time and many would
say you're 100% establishment guy right
from your background and who you work
with the guys you represent a lot of
people put those guys as establishment
many would let me ask the question and
you can you can rebuttle say whatever
you want to say so but what I want to
know like when I watched him a lot of
people would say dude this guy's never
going to who a
15-year you know show he has on TV right
right and then he's a billionaire in New
York he's loved by everybody Tupac talks
about him rappers talk about him but to
be a president there's no way this is
just a publicity stunt and by the way
most of us thought it was just a
publicity stunt he's a marketer all he's
trying to do is make himself relevant
and put himself out there and then all
of a sudden when he wins you're like
what the hell Hillary Clinton with the
resume that she had everybody thought
it's done this is her job she's going to
be the first female president she was
devastated the rumors and stories about
her being upset screaming hollering even
though she made the phone
call and then you go look at Biden and
he say how did this guy win you know
boring can't keep him but maybe because
they hated the other guy so is campaign
different on every year because it
varies based on who wins and then Obama
you look at a one-term senator ends up
doing this and then you look at
President Bush you know and then you
look at so is there a correlation for
you to say Pat these are five things you
got to look at that somebody stands a
chance at winning is there there
something like that in your world I
think
that it's not so much five but here's
the test here's the question you're
asking
so during McCain's campaign I used to
have to go and have secret meetings with
Roger ales right you'd go up and you'd
see Roger and um they'd bring you up
which you found out later in the
elevator that empty right into his
office uh that he would bring the women
up in right later and right so so I've
been in the Roger Al secret elevator
you'd go in there full disclosure he
never made a pass he never he never made
he never he never made a pass have to do
any twirl he never he never made a pass
there was there was nothing going on
there was always a huge cheeseburger
waiting W um right so you'd have lunch
with him we never had a meeting with him
where he didn't unlock the gun that he
kept under his under his safe wave the
gun around the room talk about honest to
God right talk about BR gun to the
meeting he would he would pull the gun
out from the gun safe he would talk
about some rapid response team that was
10 minutes from his house because the
terrorists were going to get him I mean
he was as big a whack job um as I as
I've ever encountered in my in my life
sitting there but brilliant right media
wise what he said was and he and he
pulls out a frame of a Time Magazine but
it's just empty he says this is what you
got to do he goes you gota you got to
put the guy's picture or the woman on
the on the Time Magazine with the word
president just look at the picture oh
wow right and he goes if you look at the
picture right and you start laughing
right you're like the right you
know that person's not going to make it
it's as simple as that so so you know
right there are there are people right
like when you see Tom Brady right when
you see an Aaron roders right there they
come along once a generation there is a
John Kennedy there is a Barack Obama
there is a Bill Clinton and there's a
there's a Ronald Reagan um people that
are skilled and then there are people
that are practitioners of
politics that have a genius of sort
Franklin Roosevelt Abraham
Lincoln when you can combine that talent
for
politics
extroversion comfort with
people that you understand and and most
people in politics don't understand
this culture is at the
headwaters politics is below the
culture politics is not the headquarters
where culture flows out of most
politicians right think it's politics up
here they also think the race is about
them as opposed to the American people
who think it's about them so the skill
the
endurance the character test you just
know looking at that person if they can
play ball great example Scott Walker so
Scott Walker governor of Governor
Wisconsin you just looked at him as a
guy people talking about who run
campaigns was like this guy's a one daa
quarterback he's not playing in the
league right he's not he's not were
saying this guy could be the next
president and it's the same with Dan
sanis right and you know Dan sis is just
the guy right who is not going to make
it at the presidential level the
difference and I say this to people all
the time I just said this to somebody
who was who's thinking about doing this
someday and I said the difference
between running for governor and Senate
is the difference between being a
commercial pilot uh running for
president being an astronaut these two
things have nothing to do with each
other other um and so it's a it's a
brutal test why in what way so you're
saying Senate and Governor is different
than president in what way because some
would say the santis was one the one of
the most successful governors in in
during Co even though you guys made a
video saying he's the worst Governor but
I'm in Florida because of him so but why
would you say Governor Senate is
different than president because a
governor and a senate race can
compensate with television advertising
that can make a difference in a
presidential race none of the
advertising really particularly matters
right it is about an
accumulation of information that sets a
narrative and a frame nationally that in
the
end falls into a frame of a choice right
so some people look at a presidential
election incorrectly it'll say it's a
referendum on the in on the incumbent
it's never a referendum it's a choice
right typically between A and B and in
this election it may be between AB b c d
and a right you may have five known
candidates ultimately ultimately on a
ballot but typically right the the race
is a choice and that's and that's what
it all devolves to so okay so so to me
what I took away from what you said is
culture over politics some guys thinks
about politics because that's the world
they're in so all they talk about is
politics like a the santis policies you
can outschool anybody cuz Jag military
Congress he's been around so that's his
world but the average person doesn't
relate to that kind of like how you said
4,300 miles you went acrosses see what
4200 miles what people are thinking or
talking that's not their language their
language is a different language do you
think that's why Trump did so well and
he won 2016 what what Trump is at its
core is a philosopher of fucku ism okay
so you have 60% of the country that's
living paycheck to paycheck
40% don't have $400 cash available so
one of the things right just in this
moment that were constantly told in the
country by the media and I and I and I
don't like the phrase the media because
it is fragmented it's not
monolithic but the thing that we're told
over and over again as a construct is
that the country is a hopelessly divided
and B evenly divided it's not
true 75% % of the country politically
does not want the Biden Trump rematch we
agree on that 75% is a big number you
you have three out of four people in the
country so that includes people who like
Trump don't like Trump like Biden don't
like Biden don't want the
matchup when you have trust that
collapses to the degree that it is
collapsed across the board every
institution Catholic Church Boy Scouts
in the culture now the military is going
over the cliff as well right collapse of
trust when you lower the expectations to
zero which is that people have no
expectation that government's going to
do anything for
them when you take away all
expectation you get a guy like Trump
says well I'll deliver a you to the
people that you blame
for the loss of the American
dream the loss of your home eight years
ago the pressure that you feel and so
Trump delivers every day he never fails
he has all the
people that
condescend to everyone in the country we
had an opu epidemic and still do in
America that was invisible had a million
people that were killed it was invisible
as a national issue to
2016 so so Trump is their vessel right
people
saying you right
to some of the largest wealth inequality
in American
history people by a broad economic
category more stressed and stretched in
some key metrics than they were on the
eve of the Great ression so it is a tale
of two
Americas and there's an absence of
anybody's ability to communicate the
inherent morality of the American free
enterprise system to lift people up from
their economic circumstances to
something better in life and our
politics so that's why Trump took off um
I was the first person on television
when everyone said he was a clown in a
joke um according to Trump I was the
first person to say no we can win
because he was saying out loud uh things
that um no one else says but millions of
people scream at their television set
and though Trump lied 35,000
times at some level he's the most honest
president we've had because there's an
inherent truth in Trump's
observations that he offers in a dialect
of plain English that
resonates with normal
people who don't
trust what they see out of Washington DC
what they see out of Wall Street and
so he is in my
estimation a world class demagogue that
has risen in a time of corruption and
collapse trust who has put forward a
proposition that is extremely
dangerous which has to do with who gets
to lead the country because our entire
Society is constructed around the person
who does is the person who wins the
election and you talked about at the
beginning my range of experiences one of
the 10 guys
the thing I think that's unique about me
on a very small list is I'm the guy who
played the concession phone call for a
defeated presidential candidate and I've
been on both sides of winning campaign
losing campaign winning is more
fun but you have a duty as an American
that supersedes everything in that
moment and in that moment when John lost
and it was clear in that evening it was
not a time for
the first black American had
just been elected president of the
United
States said to him we've fallen short
polls have closed so you don't wanted to
press turnout for other Republican
candidates out there I was the person
who picked up the phone and the first
person who addressed Barack Obama as Mr
president-elect in this country who
mattered was John McCain and that and
that
continuity is a is a
sacred
trust
a miracle in this in this country that
has gone
on uh for almost 250 years unbloodied
until the day that it wasn't so what's
your point of saying that the last part
are you saying that to say that Trump
didn't do that that he didn't make the
call or are you saying that I'm saying
that I'm saying saying that Donald
Trump um has
refused to recognize the validity of an
American election got it okay so uh uh
let's let's stay on that was a very
interesting uh take on Trump on what he
did now do you think for yourself on
locking on to a candidate to help him
become a president do you think you need
to be a person that fully believes in
that candidate or are you such a good
campaign manager that you don't even
have to like the guy you can help the
guy win no I it's too intimate a space
to
um to hate the person right it it
wouldn't it wouldn't work um at all but
I've never worked for somebody that I've
been down the line agreement on on any
issue right if you if you agree with
someone on 80% of
issues um or even 75% and you work in
you work in
politics um that's where you are and I
grew up in New Jersey I was from the
moderate wing of the Republican party I
was one of the first Republicans of um I
guess any prominence to give a speech in
favor of gay marriage so I I was always
outside whether it was on abortion
issues on on this from you know the
majority of the of the Republican party
but there was room in the Republican
party for
moderates uh during that period of time
when I was up and coming in you know
when I was up and coming in politics I I
asked this because I know I read
somewhere that you you didn't actually
vote for McCain even though you were his
campaign manager that's what I'm asking
so is there is there and is that true by
the way that you didn't actually did not
yeah so how does that work so I'm going
to be a campaign for a guy that I don't
believe should be the president how am I
going to help that guy win well I well I
started out very deeply believing he
should be the president um and
John I've written about this uh was a
complicated
guy um there was a lot of Chaos in the
in the campaign
um and it was a very disillusioning
experience in a in a lot of ways but you
know by the time I got to the end um
having seen everything that that I saw I
just couldn't couldn't do it and so I
was a volunteer um you know John called
me when he was Belly Up bankrupt Fallen
to last place campaign had collapsed I
never got paid um you never got paid
never got paid um I believed in them no
I think at the end I got a $25,000
reimbursement check but I got no income
um what should you have made to run a
campaign for the couple million so the
McCain
campaign I shut down I shut down my
business uh completely and stepped off
boards resigned a TV contract to start
the Lincoln project so politics for me
is about
conviction I have made a living giving
advice um you know fundamentally when
you talk about politics and campaigns
you know um vice president Cheney said
this to me once right he says you know
listen you come in here any time uh in
I'm in the decision making business
you're in the advice giving business and
that's you know and I've I've made a
career giving advice you know to people
in a you know under under constant fire
right it's like so you're you're just
you you are would you think about a
company that has a bad story right think
about budlight right with Dylan mulany
and all and all that presidential
campaign is that story times 100 24
hours a day 7 days a week for two
years right and so how you navigate
through that
um you know is a is a unique kind of
skill set I suppose so so let's let's go
back to this last thing personally this
is purely selfish questions I'm asking
I'm not asking this forence I'm asking
it for me
um campaign manager okay representing
somebody and you know helping that
person out
what is what is a quality of a great
campaign manager your job right not the
player we've talked about the player
already I love what Bush said he says
listen who's the biggest political
strategist in this room is a Carl roow
no it's me right my family my dad
Prescott you know my brother all this
stuff he's right what a what a great
perspective to give he's going to lose
cuz he's an right and I'm going
to win he knows like what he's talking
about right okay and kry was also a
flipflop a little bit and that kind of
hurt him but from the campaign what made
makes a great campaign manager like if
you were to in your world there are
names that you would say these are the
top five campaign managers of all time
right what do they all have in common
what's the strength of a campaign
manager at a
well data and Technology have
fundamentally
transformed
campaigns even over my
career what it what it would have been
interes is somebody who can do three
things
simultaneously help distill a message
that's understandable
incomprehensible James Carville it's the
economy stupid 19
1992 two
technically you have 50 states you have
3,000 something counties some 10,000
number of precincts Beyond that what is
the
mathematical
proposition that you have to kind of lay
out stake out project be right about get
the votes to
win how do you raise the money and how
do you spend the
money without going
bankrupt uh which is easier said than
done when you're trying to balance out
cash flows to John expenditures I mean
there were days in the Schwarzenegger
campaign in
2006 where we would make a media Buy on
a Friday afternoon for $3.5
million and have $6,000 left in the
checking account of the of the campaign
right for the for the next week so you
have to you have to stay steady you have
to stay calm you have to be able to keep
your elevation stay on the picture not
to
um not to get sucked under the the tide
on any on any day there's a lot of stuff
going on and then like I think there's
like three types of people in the
world and let me before I do that
because I think most campaign managers
are the type three
but almost all the really good at
presidential level campaign managers
typically in my career have have shared
in common a lot of us were short of
credits on our college
degree um we were all C
students we all went to State
universities um came up from middle
class background so one of the things
you said before right like on the you
know on the establishment like your
establishment Trump's outside Donald
Trump grew
up an immense privilege and wealth went
to University of Pennsylvania
and his daddy stroked them checks that
he built a real estate Empire on
um and and filed bankruptcy running
casinos right if one of us is in the
establishment it it's not me it's it's
him and um the three types of people
right I would say are this is that you
know first group right you see some type
of crazy scene going on right like the
catty Shack pool party right first type
of person sees that right and and says
like yeah right and jumps right in
second type of person sees that and it's
like I'm getting out of here right third
type of person walks in there and says
stop it right and and tries to bring
order and you know I think the dumbest
type of person in
the human realm is the type three but
but most campaign managers are type 3es
right you have a you have every day you
you have a giant production of planes
buses shows Live
Events um just just that element of it
is a is an
enormous complicated logistical
Enterprise before you have the first
aspect of of Politics on it it's an
interesting it's an
interesting Ecology
of organizations in a a modern campaign
uh so so Steve um from a campaign
manager perspective Ronda Santos's whole
campaign uh what what do you think went
wrong I mean we have we have our
opinions what do you think went wrong
Steve and if it was you in there
regardless like you said you like him
hate him whatever what would you have
done different to try to save this ship
he was um so he so this is what he he
should have done wrong um I'll tell you
what he did wrong so first off it helps
in a presidential campaign to have a
sense of his his right you have you have
so few people working in campaigns today
right around these campaigns know
anything about presidential campaigns
right the history of them uh campaigns
in general and really you know Ron Des
sis had an opportunity to do what Bush
did in
2000 um and which was a model of the
William McKinley campaign it used to be
in American politics that it was
unseemly
uh for a candidate to seek the office
right so they didn't campaign so the
first modern campaign was really the
turn of the 20th century with with
William McKinley Teddy Roosevelt
ultimately started asking for the vote
but before then people would come to the
front porch and be like you're the guy
you should run for president person
might go give some speeches write some
write some letters but with Ronda sanis
in the immediate aftermath of the of the
election he literally didn't need to
leave the governor's mansion all he had
to say at a moment where Trump's numbers
were pointing down the santis was ahead
in the race is to do what Bush did in
2000 every
wealthy magga contributor would have
been made to literally cross the
threshold of the property line right of
the Florida Governor's Mansion right to
come across literally an act of Crossing
from Trump to danis and then when they
walked out there would have been pressed
there in a camera and they would have
said what a genius the guy was and how
they're totally for him that's
fundamentally what Bush did in 2000 and
and danis had that moment to take
control but he but he didn't do it
instead he did what he did and he just
fell flat and there's
no you asked something before there's a
there's a picture of danis it's the the
pavement is dry um he's wearing white
rubber
boots right he's got he's got he's got a
vest
on and I'm like hey
man right
like I didn't pick out the outfit but I
know for sure whoever wears that outfit
is never going to be presentent right
like that's just that's just the way
that's just the way that's the way it is
yeah it's like you're
not that ain't the look that's not
presidential the factor that's not going
to be on the cover of Time Magazine
anytime soon
that's I
can't I mean I just
unless yeah right I mean can I ask you
about Trump specifically I actually
respect how you kind of framed the whole
situation it doesn't sound like
you are the one of those blindly
ignorant people they're like I just hate
him and I don't like what you actually
gave him credit you said he's a
worldclass demagogue right so there's
sort of like a humble brag right there
but you know who he is and you respect
your enemy you know Pat's newest book
choose your enemies wisely you've chosen
Trump as your enemy whether uh that's
vocal or not um you kind of laid out the
the top three uh characteres of uh the
type of person to run a campaign I want
to talk about the Trump voter you know
as as uh Bill Mah famously said it's
okay for you to hate Trump but you can't
hate the people that vote for him so in
my opinion there's three types of Voters
that votee for Trump there's the I love
my poorly educated people you know like
the Trump base you know millions of
people that just whether it's tribalism
whether it's instinctual they're just
like that's my guy you know he said he's
the middle finger to America and
rightfully so for some people right
they've been screwed over manufacturing
you talked about personal finance issues
um paycheck to paycheck all that right
that's number one on the other side of
the spectrum you have maybe the donor
class the millionaires the small
business owners in some capacity that
are look I'm I'm just voting for tax
reasons you know it's the economy stupid
so let's put those two on the on the
separate wings but then you have the
majority of people let's say it's 60% of
the people of the 80 million votes or
whatever the 76 million votes who are
like just like no I don't like what's
going on the left I'm more I'm a
conservative I'm a Christian I'm you
know I want to raise my children in the
right way at the end of the day Trump
could say what other heavy wants to say
those people are going with him and
these are hardworking Americans these
are people who love America they love
freedom they love democracy so at what
point are those people like they have a
voice too it's not like they are being
Gunn to their head you have to vote for
Trump you know you've been with Lincoln
project very adamantly against Trump
what would you say to those people who
essentially you're trying to convince
those types of people not to vote for
Trump but they're going to vote for him
anyway how do you handle that I don't I
mean these people at some level are my
parents okay right right so this is this
is family this is I mean my I was on the
Trump bomber Target list I didn't get a
bomb but apparently when the FBI came to
the house I was at the top of the next
batch um my parents still voted for
him job right right so I I don't I don't
hate I don't hate the Trump voters um
you know I love some of them very much
um here here's what I would say
to the many millions of people that are
watching this that that vote for
Trump I get
it I I get the disdain the
corruption within the
system there's a painting in the capital
of the United States it's a painting of
George
Washington
and this is the moment that
America
functionally comes to
life in the painting George Washington
is in uniform there's a chair there and
the and the
chair is is bigger than the others in
the room it's the
throne that he will not sit on and
Washington lays his cloak over it he
will not
Caesar and he bows to the
Congress he walks away from Power
twice our American
civilization our our way of
life is
constructed around the assignment of
power through the result of an
election where
lawfully people raise their hand take an
oath and they're giving limited power
for a limited period of time and never
have the power to interfere with some
basic
rights the first time Donald Trump said
in
2015 the election
results are only legitimate if I
win should have been a moment of a
national timeout I care if you're on the
far
left you're on the far
right in this
country that's not how it
works and so over these
years we've seen the escalation of that
to a moment where I think it's in real
danger if I was running that fox debate
my first question would have been let's
talk about how we're going to execute
General
Millie right we're going to shoot him we
gonna hang them poison them gas them
what do you think how how are we going
to shut down Comcast in
MSNBC and
NBC I think and I don't understand why
not because I have a very basic premise
I take everything that everyone says
literally and
seriously
period if you say you are running
to seek
retribution to kill the joint CH Chiefs
of
Staff okay we we got a
problem right what what we share in
common in this country is a is a lineage
of
defiance of
Entrepreneurship of pioneer
Spirit of of a defense of an
idea serving in the 101st
Airborne
um these are sacred things in this
country and there's no man who is who is
above them and so in a choice between
two flawed parties to flawed people I I
get
it but at this moment as we come into
the third decade of the of the 21st
century country's got real problems it's
got real opportunities I personally
think if if you had a dollar to invest
anywhere in the world you're a if
this is the place you don't put the
dollar um this is the most competitive
Society on Earth but man is our politics
broken broken and when you got a guy
like
Menendez right um who comes out and
you're like okay let's hear it right I
hear it right and he's like no you don't
understand right I had to sew the money
into the jacket it's cuz of the old
country
got years I got to be ready a country he
wasn't born in he's never he's never
been into right so it's like it's
constant and I get it Joe Scarboro said
this like on on Morning Joe the other
week and this is totally true mhm he
said every single Democrat who comes on
the
air 100% of them
say on the air something completely
different from what they say off the air
regarding Biden and here's the deal it
was exactly the same way with the
Republicans about Trump in 2015 and
2016 and either way both
sides the American people get this they
they completely intuitively understand
it's all whether it's Mendez in
the all in the old
country Diane Feinstein um passed away
right before before we came on air um I
was actually talking to someone about
this yesterday right like the the
notion this person who's a who's a
legitimately
important figure right in American
political history for for women uh the
how she came to how a power completely
stripped of her dignity in The Last 5
Years of her service that that this is
what she'll be remembered for is is is
sitting up there uh with no faculties no
no no personal agency so so we have a we
have a massive problem you have a
belligerence in the media that you see
assert itself every time someone says
well you know 80% of the country doesn't
want Trump or Biden um so there's a lot
of Brokenness I understand it but the
issue with Trump that's front and center
it has to
be are the intimations towards violence
towards chaos and the assassination
baiting of a guy who spent his entire
career wearing the cloth of the Qui
quick followup it it would seem to me
your biggest issue would be people
clinging to power let me explain Trump
first and foremost but you you named
names you named Diane Feinstein clinging
to power she was clearly a vegetable but
she wouldn't St down Bob Menendez
clearly corrupt clinging to power right
Mitch McConnell 80 years old can't even
function clinging to
power your biggest fear is Donald Trump
clinging to power you use the George
Washington example he's not King George
he's not Julius
Caesar what's go deep go dark here for a
second he clings to power let's say he
actually wins or even doesn't win this
next election but clings to power
assumes he wins how dark could it
possibly get what's your biggest fear
there's a there's a plan it's on the
table by elements at the Claremont
Institute
um that seek to really dissolve the
functioning of the government the Deep
State as they call it within six
months there is no deep
State
uh there's
dysfunction there's
bureaucracy there's INE
efficiency Steve there's no deep State
no come on Steve no there's no deep
State what is the Deep
State okay so what what do you think
when you think
about um what world economic Forum Claus
Schwab is doing and his campaign build
back better being the same campaign
identical W as
Biden's what do you think about when you
see what some of these ESG guys are
doing you know you got these uh you know
State Street you know Vanguard you know
Larry Black Rock they own all these
stocks and these 88% of S&P 500 top
three shareholders is their
institutional money and they're imposing
their power over these CEOs to do what
they need to do for you know dot dot dot
and now recently they're stepping away
from it there's a lot of people today
that I I know when you're sitting here
going through some of this stuff and I
want to I want to listen to you because
I want to know where your motive is I
want to know where your frustration lies
and you know I want to comment on a a
few of these things and then you know
give a question back to you you said
Trump being uh he was raised with a
father with money his father bailed him
out gave him money and all this other
stuff
right I saw
kids who grew up poor and I saw kids who
grew up with money the kids that grew up
with money had more Temptations to do
stupid things than the kids who grew up
poor now what do I mean by this they're
spoil brats they're annoying they're
obnoxious they're always getting bailed
out they never get suspended if they do
the D comes in and buys it out you're
not going to see a you know kid with a
rich that getting uh what's the word not
suspended when getting kicked out of
school expelled it's just not going to
happen right you're going to get these
things so the way I see it with Trump is
here's a guy that had access to all the
drugs anything he ever wanted to do he
had access to all the alcohol anything
he wanted to do he had access to all of
it
and you mean to tell me this guy never
did drugs he never never did alcohol and
with all the Temptations of the money
that his dad had he takes whatever the
dad gave him whether it's nothing a
million or 14 million I've heard all
these three numbers
right even if it's the 14 million that
his dad gave him you take that 14
million and you turn it into two billion
three billion whatever the number is
Democrats will say it's closer 2 billion
someone say 3 billion let's say 2
billion okay you do that how many kids
do that not a a lot of them it's not
easy to do so so for me I understand the
establishment thing you know and then to
to come to today when you said something
about you know this guy got up on stage
and he said if I the only reason the
only way the election will be accurate
is if I win right not if I lose if I
lose the election as a fraud and da d d
da okay fine
cool then the hypocrisy comes out is if
he only said
it and that was the issue okay what are
you doing can't be saying something like
this do you know how many videos were
taken down for repeating what Hillary
Clinton said in 2016 that the election
was rigged you know how many videos were
taken down Zero YouTube didn't take down
any videos that they said 2016 election
was rigged in Russia collusion zero
videos they all stayed up why so so
think about the the voter who uh uh you
know you're like this voter right this
voter is kind of like you know what F
you okay you want to do this I don't
like I don't like I don't like seeing
people being taken advantage of that
voter is sitting there and saying I'm
sorry dude I voted for let's just say
person says that they voted for Hillary
okay but she said the same thing Trump
said three and a half years later she
funded it and now we're supposed to sit
there and say he's the bad character not
her you want me to believe that I think
there there's a big Community as well
where I guess what I want to bring back
to you is you know how typically it's
like Republican versus Democrat
okay great then sometimes it's liberal
policies versus conservative policies
great and then sometimes it's you know
anti-establishment versus establishment
right and you said earlier when Trump
was running what Trump was able to do is
bring a a public issues that nobody was
talking about the you know the drug
issue or the Border issue nobody was
thinking about that boom he put it front
and center oh damn this is really an
issue right he made a non- talked about
issue a talked about issue then we're
all looking at us and disc guy's right
let's build a wall no one ever talked
about building a wall let's build a wall
huh why shouldn't we build a wall we
never thought about this we should do
this should do that so the the part that
gets me to question uh I'm listening to
you and I'm like this guy sounds like a
reasonable guy that he can reason you
can reason you're sharp there's a reason
why all these guys have hired you over
the
years and you say your parents voted
Trump they supported Trump even with the
bomber you at the that list whatever
even your parents still voted for him
there has to there has to be something
deeper to get you guys when I say you
guys you Weaver your partners who at
that time you're no longer with them I
know 2021 you resigned but there has to
be something where got you guys to team
up against this guy that's deeper than
just you know what he's talking about
there was a real even the documentary
the five what do you call it the the
five-part documentary series that you
guys you feel hate you guys hate this
guy you know you guys were not you know
you want to do whatever you could to
destroy this guy from winning where did
that come from um did you watch the
documentary I watched uh first episode
not all five
um so so first
off what what the documentary
shows when you when you watch when you
watch the whole
thing is that just
because you are against
Trump does not mean you are better than
Trump
because most of the people in that
documentary are exactly the same people
As
Trump in this moment we see a vast Trump
industrial complex Lincoln project as it
exists today is part of it it's a
grift when I founded it did it 85 cents
of every dollar
went into the
program um today 93 cents on the dollar
goes into the pockets of three people um
lawyer yeah the lawyer Rick Wilson and
Reed gallon right in the name of in the
name of democracy right so it's all so
it's all you guys are not friends
anymore you're not you're I I walked I
walked away from it as it blew up
because of all of the Integrity issues I
was the strategist
um when you watch the whole documentary
really it was funny when that
documentary came out there was this
enthusiasm because the number one thing
that people want and and it wasn't you
know the Lincoln project people aren't
outliers all these people want to be
famous everyone wants to be famous right
so the Lincoln project in 11 months
built a followership that was larger
than the national parties right on
social media raises $100
million now when this documentary comes
out none of the people who wanted to be
famous want to talk about it I don't
want to make a peep out it what I said
right when we when they were doing I
said I'm not going to kabash
it if you guys want to do it you can do
it all I'm saying is you want to get
famous careful you don't get what you
wish
for and that's exactly that's exactly
what happened with Donald Trump
my entire life Trump has been there I
feel like I know who he is he's the guy
who stiffs the working guy in Atlantic
City he's the guy who the little
guy over and over and over and over and
over again if you grew up in New Jersey
you follow Donald Trump's career Trump
is a con man and a grifter in my
estimation I reject completely the
notion that he's a successful
businessman he's a fraud he was a TV
character a cultural figure who was able
to in a alignment of events capture very
narrowly the presidency running against
another flaw
character I don't hate Donald Trump I
hate what Donald Trump stands for I
believe he is a threat to my country and
to the American Constitution how he
incited an Insurrection that ended the
peaceful transition of power he called
for violence and violence broke out he
has
sustained for years now a lie about this
stolen election he's lied 35,000 times
as president and in the end his lies are
lies of authority that demand submission
that demand
obedience if you look objectively at the
things Trump says it is fascistic it's
fascism not according to some liberal
pundit but according to what Bonito
musolini defines fascism as be specific
how what what Donald Trump is very
specifically calling for is a
consolidation of power around him as an
individual and an expression of him as
the individual as also being the state
um what what he does not seem to
understand is the idea of the country a
pluralistic representative
democracy uh he doesn't seem to
understand the virtue uh in the
separation of powers the Dignity of the
system uh of human rights over and over
again he has fetishized autocratic
leaders from Vladimir Putin to X to
xingping and so on and so forth so o
over and over again um the rhetoric the
actions Jared Kushner walked out of the
White House and within 6 months took $2
billion in investment from the Saudi
Investment
fund one of the most corrupt
administrations if not the most corrupt
in American
history um a shattering of
norms uh talking to the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff about deploying
the military against the American people
and in peaceful protests uh mean the
list goes on and on and
on in the end uh we have some somebody
who's been indicted facing 92 criminal
counts manding of classified information
a conspiracy in an election in
Georgia um there are very very serious
charges democracy is threatened by this
man um and it's threatened by cowardice
by people who didn't oppose him I think
this is important to
understand every Republican
all of them
100% had my position on
Trump all of them every one of them got
in line except for like six of us
there's no way in the world all of them
had the same position as you did you go
back to
2015 yeah inside the Republican Party
the dominant position is Lindsey Graham
saying accurately then we get in line
behind this guy it'll destroy the
Republican party which is which is
what's going to happen uh one way or
another at the at the end of the day but
people um got in line supporting
something that they had viscerally and
adamantly opposed because they were
moral cowards um because they did not
put their convictions ahead of their
Ambitions and that's and that's a moment
right like in politics you know at the
end of the day say what you will about
me but I believe what I believe and
you're not going to find contradictions
right in the things I've said right over
the last over the last 10 12 years on
any of this stuff you know it's crazy
when I'm listening to you and by the way
you said I believe can you pull that up
I think you said January 6 was worse
than 911 your words right yeah lincol
project co-founder can you go back to
the Tweet let me see uh yeah you can
play this clip if you want to play it uh
uh it was yeah so if you can play this
clip my friend Matthew D our friend you
know talked about this he couldn't be
more right the one six attack for the
future of the country a profoundly more
dangerous event than the 911 attacks how
could you say that and in the end the
six attacks are likely to kill a lot
more Americans that were killed on the
911 attacks which will include the
casualties of the wars that lasted 20
years following it you know how you know
how the average person listens to it and
say how many how many people died during
j6 and how much did they exaggerate and
by the way to be fair maybe your
positions changed this is a little over
two years ago when you said this maybe
today it's a different position do you
still hold the position as j6 was worse
than 911 I do H how how is that
possible because the January 6th attack
was an attack
incited by a president of the United
States of
America on the country
and the
Constitutional peaceful transfer of
power the 911 attack was never an
existential threat to the United
States Abraham Lincoln talked about this
in
1860 he said the most powerful European
Army could March land it will never take
a sip of water from the Ohio river that
if we're to destroy ourselves it'll be
through an act of National
Suicide that was the preface to the act
of National
Suicide the capital building of the
United
States is the Citadel of our
democracy these people on the
floors they desecrated the building a
Confederate flag was carried through the
Rotunda and two years later the
extremist movement in the country is
bigger better
funded and the amount of people who have
walked away from the elemental idea of
the country which is elections has
grown that's why I say that the
bloodiest war this country's fought was
the ctional war between each other and
that was prefaced by 10 years of
political violence in the
1850s it is impossible to look at the
rhetoric and not conclude that we are
barreling
towards uh violence political violence
and and when the history of the era will
be WR it will it will land squarely on
the shoulders of Donald Trump and and
let me just say on on
9/11 my father spent months as a 9/11
recovery
worker um I grew up in northern New
Jersey um it was an appalling
horrific
event but the killers who attacked us
that
day really underestimated the country
and thought that you
could damage the
country by damaging our buildings and
killing our
people America's enemies have killed a
lot of
Americans but they have
never come
close to killing the idea the idea of
the
country the the birth of the United
States is is the most important event
that happens after the birth of Christ
and
Muhammad to human
civilization the expression of an
idea all men are created equal End dowed
by a creator with inalienable rights
include life liberty the pursuit of
happiness at the Battle of
Yorktown the Marquee de Lafayette is in
command of americ
troops and when the British raised the
White Flag Lafayette says something
remarkable he says
Humanity has its
Victory Liberty has its
country and what he
believed was inexorably slavery would be
abolished though he accurately predicted
its last hold out would be in the Deep
South he predicted that the United
States would save Europe which is did in
The Next
Century that the
idea was
Transcendent
incandescent and would spread all over
the
world that's why the attack on January
6th was worse than the
attack on September 11 do you really
believe what you're saying right now
100%
2,977 people died during absolutely and
and one person died in j6 some say five
but it's one person she was shot that's
not how I measure that's not how I
measure the severity of those of those
attacks and what do you say with a ray
EPS that's in there saying get in there
you know get into insiders encouraging
people to go and he comes afterwards and
it's being talked about and you know he
he is Let Go free even though he was the
one that is also doing it but he gets a
small little of misdemeanor other guys
are still doing you know you realize
like the average person watches so
here's what the average person does
forget about about me and you the
average person watches this and and has
to decide between you and maybe my
position right they're going to say okay
I hate let's just say they hate Trump
okay all right so they're gonna try to
do whatever they can to side with you
then they hear you say j6 was worse than
911 one person died 2977 died the
difference for me between j6 and 911 was
the following 9/11 the enemy was
external and we were United a day after
9/11 nobody cared if you're Republican
or Democrat we were all
Americans a day after j6 we were
divided because it's like you voted for
Trump you're this you're a fascist
you're that dude what are you talking
about what are you talking about it was
so divisive starting with the media
doing whatever they could to destroy one
guy his reputation his life now what
they're doing they're saying marago is
worth only $18 million it's not the
proper valuation of mar lago's $8
million you talking about marago $18
million Mar is a three4 $500 million
property it's only worth 8 $18 million
so so the more and more and more they do
stuff like this you know what makes the
average person think about makes me
think about they're targeting this guy
they hate this guy they Envy this guy
they're upset at this guy maybe they
hate the fact that he's loved in ways
that they'll never be loved maybe they
hate the fact that he gets the kind of
uh from his followers because I don't
know if anybody on the
left aside from Obama I think Obama's
followers love him uh uh uh there's uh
people even on his side that voted for
Obama that say after I thought he was
going to be Obama you know he didn't do
as much for my community as I thought he
was going to do there's a lot of people
on left that have said that about Obama
but Obama has people that loved them and
Trump has people that loved them and a
part of me makes me think you know
there's a level of envy for how much
support this guy gets and then your side
you're you're sitting there and you're
okay with Hillary saying there's going
to be fraud in 2024 election or you know
we probably lost in 2016 because there
was a Russia collusion there wasn't you
know you know maybe they tamper here and
there but it's not like the dossier she
wrote $35 million and what does
everybody do n it's okay let's just move
on to the next thing this isn't that
that that important credibility is lost
then with Lincoln project it's
interesting where you are right now with
Lincoln project so Lincoln project comes
out and
says Trump is this and Trump is that and
Trump is this I think you guys won okay
what your mission was you won so credit
to you guys you had a mission you
accomplished your mission respect you
did your mission you could be an enemy
you could be a formidable enemy but
kudos to you for preventing him from
getting reelected and
you you can use the word gas light you
know whatever you want to put you drove
a lot of people from not voting for him
worked effectively yet at the same time
here's John Weaver one of the founders
is up there saying we have to go back as
a Republicans to respect men of
character because Trump's not a man of
character I like wow man of character
then what year later two years later
this guy's getting accused of 21 young
boys under the age of 18 and one 14
year-old old that he's exchanging
messages with saying I want to see
private parts or private pictures and he
says I thought it was consensual what do
you mean it's consensual with a
14-year-old boy you're talking about
character with with a trump and then
you're doing this you realize how
hypocritical by the way you resigned you
came out and you said some words about
it you realize how hypocritical that is
of a project like that that I'm supposed
to sit there and think Trump's got
character issues yet Weaver's got that
kind of character issues that's
confusing to a person let me I'm going
to I'm going to sell your confusion tell
me I'm not defending that piece of
okay number
one two though New York Times writes a
story about his secret
life the 14-year-old that he was texting
he didn't do that on the Lincoln project
he did that when he was working for John
Kasich in
2015 now I don't blame John Kasich for
that and I don't blame the Lincoln
project for it had a up guy the
incredible thing about it is the lead
correspondent for the New York times in
writing acknowledges she knew about the
guy having a secret closeted life it
wasn't kids it was adult
men
um and I didn't know I'm not a closeted
gay guy so I had no idea never saw him
physically at all during the course of
the Lincoln project he was never
physically with any person there's a lot
of people that said for decades you guys
all know how
gu no I I just told I just told you
right that I have I have no idea I have
no idea what any of your sexual
orientations
are John Weaver
though wasn't the president of the
United States joh John Weaver is a is a
political consultant who held no
position of public
responsibility I want to come back to
what you said about 911 now for a second
because I I it's the bigger thing
the passengers and crew of United Flight
93 were the first Americans to fight
back on that
day they took the plane back from the
terrorists and they crashed it into a
field in
Pennsylvania to save the United States
capital from
destruction the attack on the capital on
January 6th was a
desecration of that
sacrifice it was a desecration of the
sacrifice of every
American and it was specifically a s a
desecration of the sacrifice of the men
of the first Minnesota Gettysburg who
prevented the Confederate Army and the
Confederate flag from entering the
capital of the United States uh through
basically a suicide
charge we have in this
country uh a violence in our politics
now a rising
anti-Semitism a mainstreaming of white
supremacist extremist groups that are an
over and open part of the Trump
Coalition and it's
unacceptable there's a
whataboutism that comes up with Hillary
Clinton
and any one of a number of other people
that I don't
get I'm not a Hillary Clinton supporter
politically um wouldn't have been my
first choice I voted for against Donald
Trump but I I mean what type of
crackpipe are people sucking on if they
think that the country would have been
where it is today if Hillary Clinton had
been elected
president of the United
States wait you're saying it would have
been better if Hillary would have been
president than Trump yeah in
2016 of course of course of course
because because
because the
Democracy would not be
threatened the Democracy would not be
threatened you have a guy you mean the
establishment would have been not
threatened and protect are you troubled
by the fact that he just called for the
execution of the chairman of the Joint
Chiefs of Staff does that bother
you you're saying Hillary Clinton does
it bother you that Donald Trump just
called for the
execution of a fourstar general the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff he
just called for him to be killed do you
do you think he doesn't mean
it the fact Steve you lose credibility
when you say 297 7 people died is less
of a event than one person dying on
j6 when you it's not you're you're
you're manipulating what I said twisting
it what I said
was January 6th was a more severe attack
on the United
States September 11th September 11th
had more
casualties there's a
difference the country how do you
measure worse there's got to be data you
said you're a data guy data says one
event we lost nearly 3,000 people one
event we lost one we lost you average
person going to say of course 3,000
going to be wor because I guess I'm
counting the
600,000 that died in the American Civil
War and I'm counting the 405,000 that
died in the second world war and I'm
counting the 50,000 that died in the
Korean War and I'm counting the 58,000
that died in the Vietnam War and I'm
counting the acts of sacrifice that go
back to
1776 that were desecrated on that day in
cited by a single man who assaulted the
Constitution of the United States we
were attacked by a foreign enemy on
September 11th of 2001 the casualties
were horrendous as they were on December
7th of
1941 but the attack on January 6th was
more severe also than the attack on
Pearl Harbor well some some would call
it attack but from the videos that that
we saw Steve from Twitter and just
undercover cameras it didn't look like
an attack if just if somebody you
talking about I'm just talking about all
the videos that we've seen the oncover
what do you mean all the videos all the
videos on Twitter all the vide videos on
Twitter yeah hold on are you are you
guys gonna really sit here and
tell me that the attack on January 6th
didn't happen that the violence the
bludgeoning of the police officer didn't
happen because of some
on get the out of Steve I'll give
you Steve I'll give you my opinion and
then you could talk first of all you
comparing it's not an opinion it's not
an opinion it's a
bullsh I'm not only a New Yorker
I'm a veteran for you time out my
sister's a veteran my brother's a
veteran he's a veteran for you to
listen to me for you to say that January
6 compared to 911 is is that's
absolutely that's the dumbest I've
ever heard hold on let me finish number
one it wasn't an attack it looked like a
guy did tour okay that's what it you're
a nut are you yeah you
ain't right I am it's it was a guided
tour a guided tour you think a
guy beating the cops with all the V who
died who died Ashley babit a veteran
they shot the capital police
shot her ass where the is that guy
getting in trouble you're just upset
because that Donald Trump said you know
what they probably cheated you don't
think he has a a leg to stand on that
they did it in 200 uh uh 16
Hillary Russia FBI kud are you like how
are we crazy Steve how how are
we crazy I mean this is going to be on
video so I mean you're going to speak
for yourself no I'm going to speak for
myself four four okay 19 terrorists took
four commercial flights crashed them in
the World Trade crashed them in the
Pentagon did all that okay and you're
saying that and we've lost and you by
the way four how many decades of Wars
we've lost over a million people from
the Iraq War which is all all
lie a million people we lost a million
Americans in the Iraq war no no we lost
we we killed people cuz we said there
was weapons of mass destruction we we
lied Bush lied oh yeah there's weapons
of mass destruction there there was no
weapons of mass destructure but we were
like oh we changed the name since we're
here enduring Freedom which is
okay so as a veteran as an American as a
New Yorker for you to say that that that
one day compared to that is absolutely
absurd Steve I understand that you love
this country I'm not I'm not questioning
your patriotism but the hate for one guy
because he loves this country so much
he God you're a fool how am I a
fool how am I a fool you have you have
Trump Arrangement syndrome you just hate
him you just hate are you
are man no I'm not I didn't I guess what
country you damn right he does he's been
saying it since the ' 80s 9s on
Letterman and all these show a guy he's
a guy on September 11th who went down
said he was down there he wasn't he's a
guy who called in on a radio who said
now I got the tallest building in lower
Manhattan he's a guy who lied about
Muslims cheering it in New Jersey from
Jersey City he is a con man he is a liar
and that you have fallen for this
I'm not falling for anything
Steve please Steve how about this it
didn't it didn't have to be Trump what I
love is that this dude sacrificed
everything to pull back a curtain until
the regular American did Donald Trump
sacrifice Donald Trum sacrif his career
he can go to prison he can go to prison
for what you guys want for the rest of
have broken the law Steve you know what
it was Steve don't give me this break
law he pulled open a curtain
and let all of us see the regular
regular people look at what these
are doing F fake are you
talking about the shower curtain where
he had the country's most sensitive
Secrets doesn't bother you they all take
documents home they all take that hey
hold on were we in better shape now than
when Trump was in are you happy with
what's going on you and your Lincoln
project would mind you the biggest
Hypocrites you guys were going after him
for Russian collusion and tax evading
that's what you guys were doing all your
people you were the only one that was
innocent the rest of them were perverted
d one of them was a Russian agent one of
them was a Russian agent one of them
owes $390,000 a tax in his house and the
other guy went to court from American
Express for not paying his 30,000 tax
bill you guys are the biggest Hypocrites
the biggest Hypocrites you guys hate the
man you guys just hate the man but the
policies and what he did for this
country I'm happy listen it didn't have
to be him Steve it could have been a
Turtle he woke us up he told
people hey look look at this curtain
look at what these are doing
fake news and it's all and he
sacrifice it all for us plain and simple
Steve say what you want say what you
want you're talking to a veteran that
that that a whole family fought for this
country and my parents are immigrants
and I'm a New Yorker for you to compare
those two is asinine the only
girl that died was a veteran the capital
police shutter you said bludgeoning who
died on who died on January 6 who died
who died well we have we have multiple
suicides police off give me a mulp on
January 6 in the capital who died you're
you're I'm yeah I'm passionate I'm
telling the truth I'm telling the trth
Steve you're the one you were cussing
and talking you're not going to do
that with me I'm sorry let me tell
you something you you are sitting here
lying to millions of people about what
happened on January 6 I'm lying which
was an attack on the country incited by
the president watch the why is
is he in jail for inciting violence he
will be soon is that the video is that
the where he's like go peaceful he's
like go in there be peaceful don't
that's what happened I don't know you
guys you you guys don't seem to be a
wack job like this guy I'm a I'm
a wack job but you know you know what it
is though Steve you know what it is so
for me I want to respect the voter and I
think there are millions if not tens who
feel like he does I think I I don't give
a how he feels and this is I a fck
how you feel and this is this is
important this is important because you
can watch the video you can watch the
video you can watch the actual video of
the insurrectionists attacking the
capital that's real it happened they
attacked the capital okay can I can I
just weigh in on one thing you guys are
both wrong and you're both right let me
explain both days are horrible days in
American history we're comparing what's
worse of a tragedy when they're both
horrible tragedies so who's who right
who's wrong you're right more
symbolically correct this is an attack
on our democracy the P peaceful transfer
of power talking he's saying he's saying
it didn't happen no which he's wrong
he's saying it didn't I said I deny that
here's a question for you no no hang on
hang on hang on a second listen to me no
no hang on a second you're the judge of
this can I give you're the judge of this
to say he's wrong or he's wrong and I I
did I say it didn't I said people
weren't there you said attack said they
were they were there they were
protesting you said you said you said it
was a i no it was aour no no I said it
guid tour it didn't look like a guided
tour to me yeah what were what channel
were you watching CNN MSNBC I was
watching undercover cam you are a
festar rack job man right and wrong was
he's completely wrong where I agree with
what people say is by definition a lot
of people would say that it wasn't
literally a ins Insurrection was it a
riot was it a was it a violent protest
it was an Insurrection aimed at stopping
the certification of the election
constitutionally prescribed on January
6th that's the purpose of it you can you
can argue over semantics is that's what
I think
you're what point are you
making it's not semantic I would love to
make my point go let's see what
it finish my Fu for once make your point
hurry up for once so the point is both
days were piece of horrible
days you know it was not just a guided
tour you know that it was a violent
violent Act
of complete absurdity it wasn't a guided
tour but at the same time I don't think
many people think that it was an actual
Insurrection it was a horrible day in
American history horrible day it was not
a tour through the capital it was
horrible but at the same time you have
to understand millions millions of
Americans are going to see what you said
about 9/11 and be sh shocked by the
ramifications of what you're saying so
this is what I'm saying that you're both
right and wrong in your assessment I
think millions of Americans will
understand perfectly what I'm saying I
think millions of Americans sadly are
abused by people like you I'm Abus who
have a platform and communicate
misinformation like you just did that
this was a guided tour as opposed to a
violent attack you are one of the people
through your conspiracies who is
poisoning the discourse in the ability
of people to tell reality I want to say
for the record you're completely
absolutely totally full of
when you say when you say when you
sayos when that was anything other than
an Insurrection go use your microphone
what guess what I can say whatever I
want because by the way reasonable
question for you reasonable question for
you what was and Adam here's question
for you uh you said violent protest you
you you use those words twice he said
violent twice did you said j6 is violent
yes was BLM protest violent so we're
going to go to a separate top question
for you yes it was violent what's more
violent j6 or BLM riots how many
businesses went out of business or how
many businesses were trash during j6 now
I have to defend BL you do because you
use the word violent they were both
violent just like 911 Al a horrible day
just like January 6 level so only one
can be violent when the other one it's
not no why why can't J was only BLM was
violent I got it why why do what what
what is the difficulty in
understanding that one of them was an
attack on a very specific
place on a very specific day
with a very specific function taking
place on that
day that had everything to do with the
peaceful transition of
power which is
foundational to how the country
functions that's why now now we're
talking different
issues so so so so if there's a riot
right in Cleveland
uhhuh and 500 businesses are burned down
yeah that is a threat to the economy in
Cleveland but not American
democracy if you assault the capital
yeah on the day that the Congress is
certifying an election to begin the
process that will culminate on the 20th
with the transfer
they have nothing to do with each
other the attack on the 6th was
incited by one of the 44 people in the
history of the country who's raised his
hand and swore the 35W oath to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution of
the United States
period it was the most grotesque
betrayal and abdication of presidential
responsibility in American history it
constitutionally disqualifies him in my
estimation from holding office ever
again how could
anybody look at what
happened look at what happened it was a
tour how dare you you didn't see
the shaman getting guided around sh the
guy the guy was supposed to be this
crazy wild man they were okay here
here's my question what Steve how do you
explain the countless FBI agents in PL
uniform that Congress won't even tell us
how many because it didn't happen oh
yeah oh no no and
it violent insur oh yeah by the way what
what do you let me see this can I Sol it
go back to that video could you show
this video people are rotting in
jail for 30 years doing this what
the hell does that look like that look
like to you violence I don't give sh
just cuz you're yelling doesn't mean
you're right no doesn't matter that's
one piece of video why don't we show the
hours of footage Tucker Tucker Tucker
Carlson tuck what do we got here we got
Tucker Carlson here we got a we got a
guy we got Tucker Carlson we got a guy
who's got his own show on Russ God Rest
her soul the king of rep domestic Terror
oh my God look at this violence oh my
goodness oh my God they're up let's roll
the tape of the violence though okay
that's like saying there's a war going
on over here but you have video of
outside of them getting along there's
other video hold on let's go back so you
mean to tell me Donald Trump 2016 we
found this is a fact this isn't this
isn't BS I made this up 2016 fact all
right the DOR report Hillary Clinton DNC
FBI they all colluded to say he none of
that's true no oh oh yeah none of that's
true so you're full of right now
number one 100% true she paid for D did
all that 100% so so wait so Donald
Trump is crazy to think that they would
cheat again are you kidding me you mean
have an FBI there's no evidence of voter
fraud of any type
whatsoever you're that's a separate
conversation Hold On by way and the
hypocrisy for you guys to talk the
Lincoln project was comprised of all the
same that you guys accused Trump of
that's the funny part you guys
are all full of you your whole crew
was tax evading for Russian foreign
agent money scandling people and
we're supposed to what believe you guys
were making money where's all that money
where's all the money and we're I'm I'm
crazy how you didn't vet none of
those people you didn't vet none of them
no none of these people the and it's
always the ones that point are the
biggest pieces of the ones that go
hey look at Trump Tax Guy Russia guy it
was you guys was it me it's you oh
you're innocent you're OB you're 100% I
pay my taxes okay okay you want to find
you want to send you want to find some
guy you know what you are an
American Patriot you're aack job yeah
I'm a wack joback job let me guess yeah
right yeah dismiss dismiss conspiracy no
it the truth hurts and it
doesn't care about the feelings period
I'm sorry I'm not he's saying about the
peaceful tour of the of the capital
which I fully disagree with but opin
what he say wrong not it's not an
opinion it's not an opinion he's a liar
he's a liar he's lying into the camera
about a violent event saying it was
peaceful spot in conspiracy theories and
using a Tucker Carlson thing I I I
didn't play I mean I don't know I don't
know what to say other than other than
to say it's why the country right I mean
it's why Trump is leading in the polls
cuz I'm there so many crazy whack jobs
like me that are tired of your
period America first look where the
America is right now where where are we
are you happy with what's happening
right now in this country are you
genuinely happy with what's happening in
the country border wide
open inflation all the that's
happening all the violence all the
Smashing grabs all the you're happy
I think I think three
things I genuinely think you're a whack
job I God bless you too thank you so
much I I think you're ignorant okay
thank you um thank you and and I think
you have nothing to say because you know
that I'm right and guess what I hope to
God Trump's win again Trump wins again
so he just your head me kill theair of
the joint because I want you to wake up
every morning I want you to wake up
every morning go I want you to cry like
all the people that cried but he made
America dope it's people like you that
are dividing us all right I don't give a
about personality I want policy I
want to live in a safe country
all right I want the border to be secure
I want the economy to be killing all
right I don't want people like you like
he's a boogeyman he's a Bo
not at all bro I'm Point all day ve in
your head it's called passion nice vein
in your head I have passion what do you
think about what he's asking about
killing the Joint Chiefs of Staff as a
better for it for it kill him
right when Trump wants to kill Millie I
didn't I I he didn't hear it you didn't
hear he just said it he said it Trump
just said he wanted to kill Millie some
kill when did that happen I that
happened three days ago okay I didn't
see
it the question asking he's asking a
question about uh uh how do you feel
America's doing today we'll get to this
here in a minute as well how do you
think America's doing today
uh I think the country
is I think the country's got a bad
economy right now okay and um I think
the country
is uh when you look at the polls right
now the country is having a choice put
on it uh that it doesn't want
and so right now would you have 80% of
the country saying we don't want the
Trump Biden rematch we'll see if we even
get the Trump Biden rematch right um
Johnson didn't get out of the race until
March of uh
1968 um you know we'll see we'll see
what happens we'll see what happens if
Glenn yunan gets in um to the race from
Virginia we'll see what happens if n
Nikki Haley Pops in New Hampshire you
know Trump isn't going to go down in a
national election he'll lose in Iowa
first and then he'll lose in New
Hampshire and the candidate that could
beat him in Iowa like hasn't revealed
themselves yet but Nikki haly can beat
him in New Hampshire um and we'll see
like over over the months ahead but I I
wouldn't bet my right arm that we're
going to see a trump Biden contest at
all more because Trump's not going to
make it or Biden's not going to make it
I think that there's a scenario where
they both don't make it who do you think
is going to make it on the left um I
think the Democratic race is still very
very fluid I think look the the reality
of the of the campaign is you had a guy
go on MSNBC named cor Cornell
Belcher he's a pollster and what he said
was that Biden's age is an asset because
of his wisdom MH and so when you run a
presidential
campaign you you got to start and you
have to be grounded in
reality and reality is if you're going
out and I I think objectively this is
what the Biden campaign is saying it's
saying that this is the best economy
ever I think that's what their message
is um and
two his age is an asset and he's the
wisest guy in the
land No One Believes that so I think
that's a I think it's a very difficult
proposition and so when you look at
numbers in November in December that
consistently show him losing to
Trump there will be a different
discussion right now when you see the
numbers coming out that show a very
close race that show how much
dissatisfaction there is with him on the
economy mostly in Washington what they
say is don't believe the polls don't
don't read the polls
but um those polls are real and so I
don't think they've they've caught it up
now it's interesting because Democratic
party historically was always the more
chaotic party but they're in line right
now behind behind Biden but if this
Minnesota Congressman for example Dean
Phillips if he were to go up uh and run
against Biden in New Hampshire I think
he would do very well um you know James
Carville is shouting from the rooftops
um about people better wake the up
because 34 is a is a big is a big number
when you look at gas prices when you
look at um interest rates when you look
at real wages all of these all of these
things the economy is in in tough shape
for most people California yesterday gas
prices were 650 in California going back
to your question what are your thoughts
on Nome you'd be a very
formidable candidate we're on the same
page let me answer the question for you
guys with this Trump thing can you pull
this up so we can cuz he asked the
question I want to answer his question
so he Trump said what Trump flost the
idea of executing how did he say can you
pull up the quote on what he
said what did Trump said exact words if
you can find
it go a little lower and yet none of it
suggests what execution for but what's
the exact words and who said it who was
was it on camera I you know where he
said it I'm trying Steve the phone call
oh is this one of those what like like
he heard someone heard somebody say
Steve do you know where he said this
it's in the um he says the punishment
would have been death regarding the
phone call that he made to
China yeah well these are some
combination of Trump's tweets statements
he actually say it he actually
absolutely no I'm looking for the actual
quote of what you said that he said he
ordered death number one it's
number one it's treason to talk to China
behind the president's back that's
number one but number two not but can I
give you my number two my number two is
I don't support those words here's what
you have to realize I don't sit there
and
support every word a candidate's going
to say left or right I'm not sitting
there saying I 100% agree with 100% of
what this guy says no I don't that that
I've never been like that ever with a
person that's been a president is this
the one so let's read Mark Le will let
embarrassing moment in American history
uh uh with his gross in common
Afghanistan cost lives and handing over
billions of dollars of the finest
military equip over theer next week this
will be a time for all citizens of the
us celebrate this guy turned out to be a
woke train wreck who if the fake news
reported is correct was actually dealing
with China to give them a heads up on
thinking of the president of the United
States this is an act of egregious that
in Times Gone by the punishment would
have been dead yeah okay that's not
saying that's Prett say I was Wai war
between China and the United States
could have been the result of a
trigonous act he's right I mean I I
agree with that and he didn't say he's
got to die so that's the respon so was
fake news so you you just did basically
what the media he's calling he's calling
for the assassination the chairman of
the right the out of here F news
his word saying this is an act so
egregious that in Times Gone by the past
well first off the Act was normal
standard he was talking as the chairman
does to his counterpart in the Chinese
military to uh deconfliction reasons um
which are normal appropriate and
standard conversation to each hisone at
this point right with this area somebody
can say this is a little bit of an
exaggeration he's not saying he should
die no no listen he's Donald Trump yeah
has made intimations of
violence towards many people judges
including the chairman of joint ch's
staff this tweet other statements and it
is what it is what do you your thoughts
this read
is how do you read it I'm curious number
one by the way my mic keeps cutting out
every once what no I want I'm going to
say this and then I want to ask a
question before we wrap up but this this
is the whole thing is that it's not
literally him calling for death but the
whole premise with Trump and where where
it gets complicated is it is a lot of
dog whistling I'm not going to come out
and say it other than Russia Russia
Russia you know 30,000 emails but he
dances around hey you know typically
this is death he did capitalize death
this is the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff this was his General handpicked
so again it's not literal but it there
there is some sort of hyperbolic nature
about Trump where you can kind of
interpret it this way but if this were a
you know red flag yellow flag football
you don't know that's the whole thing
with Trump is he didn't come out and say
it but he said it can you guys hear my
can you guys
okay go for yeah well here's my qu but
let's go back to the strategy thing
because if we if we parse through all
the nonsense at the end of the day
whether 75% people want to see Trump
Biden it's looking like we're looking
heading for this train wreck if you're
the campaign manager if and when you
might even get this call uh based on
your strategic abilities you're the
campaign manager for 80-year-old Joe
Biden you know that the economy is weak
you know that people are fed up you know
that Trump is also a weak candidate
numerically um how would you go about
winning against Trump if you're Joe
Biden's campaign man well the the
extremism is the issue
and at each
time you have a carry Lake style whack
job
um running for office they tend to lose
over and over again so he needs to put
the extremism at the front and center of
the of the campaign um um and then they
also need to get an economic message
that's reality
based um because right now it's not
reality based so I believe I believe
this is my opinion that they're going to
take the footage of January
6th the not so peaceful stuff the stuff
where it's actually violence and they're
just going to pump a $100 million into
that and simply say is this what you
want more of whether it was an
Insurrection or not is irrelevant
they're going to take the worst of the
worst images and say is this what you're
voting for and where are they going to
play that they're going to play that in
Pennsylvania they're going to play that
in Detroit they're going to play that in
Iowa they're going to play that in Ohio
they're going to play it in the 100,000
swing votes that basically vote for
Obama or Trump back to Biden and how's
that going to work well I mean first off
let me let me just say we're sitting
here talking about it I honestly don't
know what the No Labels people are going
to do mhm right they they either have
the $100 million they need to get ballot
access or they don't but if they have it
and Joe mansion and John Huntsman or Joe
mansion and someone else are
running and Bobby Kennedy's running on
the libertarian
ticket and um Cornell West is running on
the green ticket it's not a twers race
right it's like just like from like a
strategic right perspective right like
it's the race is the race that is not
not the one it's not a twers Race So the
first thing that happens in a in a
three-person race with Joe man you could
have 40 competitive
States right it lowers the threshold
right to the
30s um a lot of people say that it
automatically reects Trump I'm not sure
that I buy
that
um but there's going to be a lot of
volatility ahead in politics because
we're barreling down the road at a
choice that 34 of the country says it
doesn't want and that never works out
well in the United States Steve let's
wrap it up with one conversation you one
thing you spot I can't hear myself if
you guys can hear me I'm fine but I
can't hear myself okay so you said
America would have been different if
Hillary Clinton was we wouldn't be where
we are today so uh uh a lot of people
would say of course it wouldn't be
because she is like the face of a
establishment so she would have
protected all the establishment people
and they would have been fine Trump in
the face of anti- let me just give you
my question and then Trump the face of
the anti-establishment of course is
going to ruin it for everybody else
because he's not part of their Camp he's
not part of their group he's not kicking
it with you know a McConnell or Schumer
or Pelosi or Hillary he's not part of
their Camp he's not part of that but
they hate this guy they can't stand this
guy even over the years he gave him all
the money what would America look like
with a Hillary Clinton as a president
because she probably would have been a
two-term president what would America
look like with Hillary Clinton as a
president it would have looked
like it would have looked like what
America looked like before Donald Trump
was President we would have had
a moderate Democratic
president
internationalist
um that believed in American military
power
um probably more interventionist than
where the country is where the party is
where the where the Republican party is
uh we would not uh have left
Afghanistan in the chaotic
manner uh that that we would have left
you would not have
had the complete societal chaos and
lying in you and you wouldn't have had a
president who lied to the American
people 35,000 times you're saying
Hillary Clinton hasn't lied Hillary
Clinton has lied but she doesn't lie
like Donald Trump lies 35,000 documented
lies no no person has ever no no person
has ever done that and so I guess like
when you sit and you talk about like the
establishment and the an I get the
construct right and the US and the them
and the puppet string and the they and
everything but here's the
deal Donald
Trump and everyone who worked for him
these are immensely powerful people are
are you going to tell me wilb bar Ross
isn't part of the
establishment that the hedge fund Titan
Ken Griffin isn't part of the
establishment Steve
schwarzman right of Blackstone who
funded Trump isn't part of the
establishment come on yeah don't put him
on Larry thinkink and Soros level at all
that if you're talking deep State you
know you're talking Soros you're talking
thinkink you talking no I I mean I got
some of those
guys I just want I just want to let you
know I have a big problem I have to I
have to push back on it totally fine go
forward you should think carefully yeah
about using Jewish
names and alleging Global
conspiracies right it's I I don't think
you what are you insinuating what are
you saying what what I'm saying is when
Elon Musk goes and he says it's the
fault of the Jews that he up
Twitter yeah right in the
Anti-Defamation League there is a virus
of anti-Semitism in the
air and enemal to anti-Semitism is the
con well
I a deep part of
anti-Semitism as it's expressed is
always the conspiracy yeah right
and Soros conspiracy F
conspiracy it's all it's all
nonsense lay out the
conspiracy in detail or or don't but the
assertion of some powerful flowing
conspiracy a cons against Trump SOS
Soros
spend a lot of money open Society $32
billion yeah he's Dei CI all that stuff
is through them that's the corporate
Equity index you know diversity Equity
inclusive ESG environmental social
governance and they're giving Philip
Morris the highest score and they're
giving Tesla the lowest because Elon
Musk is against them you have to realize
this isn't conspiracy this is weird what
does that have to do with politic how
does this no you you brought up Elon
Musk I didn't bring up Elon Musk how
does how does a Philip morrris gave the
G get a higher score for in the
environment than Tesla you don't think
that's like that's conspiracy to you to
me it's conspiracy on what es she is
that's not the word that's not the word
I would use I just think it's I just
think it's mostly stupid yeah
right like it doesn't make sense as a
Jew I think we got a little off track
here because I don't think that's what
he was insing at ever I think he was
just saying the more
globalist uh establishment names who
just happen to be whatever religion they
I don't I don't give a I don't
think the word the word historically
globalist code for Jew I didn't know
that this is the first time I've never
heard that before is that why you say
internationalist that's how you describe
Hillary Clinton I've never heard that
word I've heard globalist a billion
times yeah it's um no I mean globalist
is very much part of the vocabulary and
architecture of a lot of white supremacy
a lot of anti-em I think you have to be
careful with with no doubt but to hone
in on what you were saying you were
saying that he's he's basically saying
listen Trump is anti-establishment I I
think we can all acknowledge at least on
the surface The Establishment don't like
him what you're basically saying is that
everyone that worked for him from Wilbur
Ross to uh minuchin to everyone they're
all part of the establishment whether
it's Wall Street it's a scam right I I
just so you don't think that he in in
himself is anti-establishment
but the people if you wantan to if you
want to
look for a model of a president who was
anti-establishment
truly on the opposite side in every
conceivable way of the class that he
grew up
in right the party that that he led it's
it was Franklin
Roosevelt right that's an example of
somebody or Teddy Roosevelt right who
was against the establishment powers of
the country what about the last 50 where
where where there
you
have Donald
Trump is very
much in the middle of whatever it is you
define as the American
establishment right you have you have
two institutions in the country the
leaders of the democratic party and the
leaders of the Republican Party are both
part of the
establishment by definition correct if
you're running a hedge fund you're in
the
establishment right if you're in the top
1% of income you're in the
establishment period right so you have
two political
parties right that were told over and
over again never agree on anything but
what they agree on is we're going to get
the choice that they give us whether you
like it whether you like it or not and
that's the establish I don't know about
that because you're saying if you're in
the top 1% or the 0.01% you're the
establishment socioeconomically I
wouldn't say that someone like
Elon Musk is the establishment that guy
is trying to put a sledgehammer
to it I wouldn't say that someone like
Joe Rogan who's made it into the
mainstream media n clature is
establishment at all so I don't know if
I agree with your assessment just
because you're at the top of the list I
don't I don't think I don't think Joe
Rogan is Corporate
correct but Joe Rogan's in the
establishment how so Joe Rogan is his Jo
Joe Joe Rogan is a
multi-millionaire who millions of people
listen to the idea that he's somehow
outside of the
mainstream
fighting the mainstream I I just I don't
what about
Elon um I think Elon Musk is an American
oligarch um I think that Elon Musk is
and I come from a place I'm delighted by
this FTC action against Google I'm for
breaking up these companies I'm for
breaking up the concentrations of power
uh that have run a muck right that's
anti-establishment right when you're
talking about breaking up Facebook and
Google and all of these giant outof
control companies that have stifled
competition and growth in the country
that's anti-establishment fixing the tax
code is anti-establishment
reform and renewal right is is
anti-establishment
but but but I I just reject I think the
definition as laid out okay got it uh
Steve thanks for being on this was fiery
it was crazy but the audience won today
as usual that's the goal you guys want
to go get some beers after this if you
want to put the link below to his
podcast that we have so people can go
find it as well uh if you want to hear a
different perspective the warning with
Steve Schmidt again don't expect to like
everything he has to say but it's going
to be different perspective we're going
to put that link below as well gang have
a great weekend take care everybody
we'll do it again next week bye-bye
bye-bye thank you this was
great that was your headphon it's my
headph